Quand j'ai vu pour la première fois la Petite
Sirène originale, mon monde entier a changé,
comme beaucoup d'entre nous, petites filles, nous
voulions toutes juste être des sirènes.
Je pense que la petite sirène est une
histoire emblématique et puissante, il était important de
l'élargir et d'en faire une expérience plus complète.
Cette petite sirène  reflète ce que
signifie vouloir quelque chose de plus grand pour
soi-même,
c'est une voix de
Lee Bailey lorsqu'elle chantait pour nous, c'était
tellement émouvant qu'elle a placé la barre et personne ne l'a
jamais dépassée, pauvre enfant, je
t'observe depuis longtemps maintenant Jimmy
Melissa McCarthy  comme Marissa adore, elle est
extraordinaire, elle est tellement sournoise et
complice, nous avons conclu un accord, je pourrais juste
vous donner le package premium, gamin, elle est
hilarante et terrifiante, c'est vrai
que
La Petite Sirène a été le premier film que j'ai
jamais composé, c'est particulièrement émouvant
de revenir et avec Lin-manuel Miranda
qui était si brillant les chansons que nous avons
écrites développent ce qu'est la petite sirène Je
me sens vraiment fier de travailler sur La Petite
Sirène parce que ces personnages vivent dans
mon cœur
Je ne sais pas où je ne sais pas comment mais
je sais que quelque chose commence bien  maintenant,
le monde dans lequel Rob Marshall a créé de
précieuses limites, il fait quelque chose de
spécial,
c'est juste un rêve devenu réalité, une partie de votre
s
[Musique]